Music.
Herzlich willkommen zu unserer Live-Folge Dicke Bretter.
Heute von den Datenspuren in Dresden.
Ich bin Elina oder auch Khaleesi und zusammen mit der wunderbaren Konstanze
Kurz und Elisa Lindinger, die heute leider nicht da sein kann.
Werden wir heute ein bisschen über Policy-Themen reden.
Worum es genau geht, werde ich gleich verraten und wir haben auch wieder einen
wunderbaren Gast, nämlich Daniel, der sich auch gleich selber vorstellen wird.
Und in unseren vergangenen Folgen haben wir uns schon mit der UN beschäftigt
und mit der EU und mit dem Bundestag und mit Gremien,
die technische Standards machen und wir gehen jetzt in der Flughöhe wieder noch
ein Stück weiter runter und zwar soll es heute mal um Landespolitik gehen,
ganz besonders um Landespolitik in Sachsen und dazu haben wir Daniel eingeladen,
der noch Mitglied im Landtag ist.
Daniel, stell dich doch mal vor.
Ja, schönen guten Abend von mir. Ich bin Daniel.
Ich wurde gerade schon gesagt, ich bin noch Abgeordneter im Sächsischen Landtag
für die Bündnisgrüne Landtagsfraktion.
Ist so ein bisschen so ein fraglicher Status, so ein bisschen wie Schrödingers Katze.
Bin jetzt nicht noch mal angetreten, aber zumindest bis sich der neue Landtag
konstituiert hat, darf ich diesen Titel noch tragen.
Und ja, zu mir, ich bin Sachse, mein ganzes Leben lang schon und ich komme aus
dem Herzgebirge, aus Bad Schlema, falls das jemand was sagt.
Und seit 2004 in Leipzig, da habe ich Informatik studiert,
promoviert an der Uni Leipzig und danach mal so ein IT-Startup gegründet,
was sich mit Erreichbarkeitsanalysen und Optimierungsproblemen in Straßen und ÖPNV-Netzwerken...
Ah, heute wollte man KI sagen, oder?
Nein, das war Dijkstra und so weiter, das war, also es war komplizierte Technik,
aber das war auf jeden Fall ohne KI.
An der Stelle nochmal vielen Dank an die OpenStreetMaps Community,
ohne die wäre das definitiv damals nicht möglich gewesen, dass man das machen kann.
Von daher, wahrscheinlich wir werden ja noch auf offene Daten und so weiter
zu sprechen kommen, nehme ich mal an großer Dank.
Genau und seit 2019, wie gesagt, Mitglied im Sächsischen Landtag,
darf da die Themen Digitalisierung, Energiepolitik und Klimapolitik,
also ich habe es versucht auch ein bisschen miteinander zu verbinden,
vertreten und das hat mir sehr großen Spaß gemacht.
Ich habe da sehr viel gelernt und jetzt, wie gesagt, die letzten Tage als Abgeordneter
und heute dankenswerterweise im Podcast.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung. Unser Podcast heißt ja deswegen Dicke Bretter.
Also Kelly, sie hat es ja schon ein bisschen angedeutet, weil wir vor allen
Dingen mal so ein bisschen erklären wollten, wie Politik eigentlich entsteht,
wie politische Willensbildung eigentlich passiert, ganz praktisch.
Deshalb haben wir die verschiedenen Ebenen, die Kelly sich schon angesprochen
hat, ein bisschen beleuchtet, meistens an irgendeinem konkreten Thema.
Und das war auch der Grund, warum wir hier auf den Datenspuren ganz gerne einfach
mal über Landespolitik reden wollten.
Natürlich mit einem gewissen digitalen Einschlag. Und wir wollten gerne einen
Praktiker hier haben, der uns sozusagen unsere Fragen beantworten kann.
Aber die erste, die mir gleich kam, als ich so las, Daniel Gerber,
der ist ja Informatiker, war eine ziemlich naheliegende.
Wie kommt es sozusagen nach dem Studium und ein bisschen oder jeweils ein paar Jahre in der Praxis,
irgendwie Softwareentwicklung und Unternehmensgründung, dann sein Leben,
wenn man ja mal sagen, umstellen muss, so ein Berufspolitiker zu werden.
Also wie kommt man als Informatiker in den Landtag und wie läuft das ganz praktisch
ab, wenn man sich für digitale Themen interessiert?
Also das war so eine naheliegende Frage und die würde ich dir jetzt auch gerne stellen wollen. Ja.
Wir hatten es ja auch schon mal kurz im Vorgespräch jetzt angesprochen.
Ich habe 2016 so ein einschneidendes Erlebnis gehabt.
Wahrscheinlich haben wir das irgendwie alle gehabt. 2016 war das ja,
in dem zwei Dinge passiert sind.
Also bestimmt viele andere auch, aber zwei Dinge, die für mich besonders relevant
waren. Und das war zum einen der Brexit und danach Donald Trump.
Ist ja jetzt leider jetzt gerade wieder aktuell.
Aber das waren auf jeden Fall zwei Dinge, die mein Leben in gewisser Weise erschüttert
haben. und dazu geführt haben, dass ich Dinge hinterfragt habe,
die ich für Gott gegeben gehalten habe und wollte damals irgendwas tun.
Ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, dass die EU, wir waren auch in Frankreich noch in
dem Jahr, Penn war da auch schon groß und für mich hat die EU gewackelt.
Das war ein Wunsch aus mir heraus, da irgendwie mitzuhelfen,
dass es vielleicht noch nicht zu spät ist und man da noch irgendwie mithelfen kann.
Und dann hat sich für mich ein bisschen die Frage gestellt, wie.
Die Antwort, die ich mir damals gestellt habe, war auch noch im Hinblick von
Klimakrise und so weiter, was da alles noch mit dran hängt.
Irgendwie, ich muss irgendwie in die Politik gehen, weil ich sehe,
wir laufen in die falsche Richtung.
Und dann waren es für mich eben die Grünen, die da die größte Schnittmenge mit meinem Denken harten.
Und dann habe ich so langsam angefangen und bin in die Parteipolitik reingegangen.
Interessanterweise gab es auch, wir waren im Vergleich zu jetzt schon ein sehr
kleiner Landesverband 2016. Und dann bin ich direkt als nach sechs Wochen Mitgliedschaft
irgendwie Sprecher der LAG Europa und Internationales geworden.
Und dann habe ich das zwei Jahre gemacht. Dann war ich Sprecher für Digitale
und Medien, weil sozusagen da mein Herz hängt.
Und 2019, sozusagen auf der Höhe der Klimaproteste und Fridays for Future und
so weiter, gab es für mich die Möglichkeit,
über die Landesliste bei den Grünen da zu kandidieren und habe dabei sicherlich
auch mit dem Informatik-Background eine politische Lücke bedient,
die so niemand anders hat.
Also es gibt jetzt ein paar, die dann nachgekommen sind, aber trotzdem schon eher so eine Orchidee.
Also auf jeden Fall die Ausnahme in der Politik.
Und dann hatte ich damals noch einen Vollzeitjob, den habe ich quasi nach unten
gescaled, habe Verantwortung da abgegeben, um da Verantwortung zuzunehmen.
Und dann hat sich das eins mit dem anderen ergeben. Und ich habe das nie bereut.
Ich empfehle jedem mal in den Sächsischen Landtag zu gehen, das ist eine absolut prägende Erfahrung.
Es ist eine große Ehre für mich, da so viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger und so weiter
zu vertreten und für, keine Ahnung, eine gerechtere Welt und so weiter zu streiten.
Vielleicht können wir da gleich mal ansetzen, weil ich glaube,
das ist total spannend, so auch als Person, die jetzt nicht schon sehr viel
Politikbetrieb mitgenommen hat, bevor sie in den Landtag gezogen ist.
Fühlt sich wahrscheinlich genauso an, wie wenn man das erste Mal als Aktivist
mit dem Landtag zu tun hat.
Wie ist das so, da anzukommen? Da muss man sich ja wahrscheinlich so in die
Strukturen reinfinden.
Wie viele Mitarbeitende hat
man in einem Landtag? Wie sieht eigentlich so der Ankommensprozess aus?
Politikerin. Ich befürchte, dass ich nicht dir die Standardantwort geben kann,
die normalerweise Leute darauf antworten, weil das bei dieser Legislatur,
also diese Legislatur war geprägt von der Corona-Pandemie und dem ukrainischen,
also dem völkerrechtswidrigen Anschlusskrieg Russlands in der Ukraine.
Das sind zwei Dinge, die glücklicherweise in Anführungsstrichen normalen Legislaturen nicht passieren.
Aber ich bin als Basismitglied von heute auf morgen in Koalitionsverhandlungen geworfen worden.
Gestern irgendwie irrelevant. Heute sitzt du mit dem Verkehrsminister irgendwie
am Tisch und musst verhandeln.
Wir sollten kurz einmal erklären für die, die nicht aus Sachsen kommen,
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit wem war das damals? Das waren doch die Christdemokraten, oder?
Wir haben in Sachsen eine sogenannte Kenia-Koalition, Also eine Koalition aus
CDU, Bündnisgrün und SPD,
wobei natürlich die Wahlergebnisse in Sachsen so sind, dass die CDU die größte
Fraktion ist und SPD und Grüne ungefähr gleich groß.
In einem klitzkleinen Vorsprung, auf den wir immer bestehen,
aber im Grunde genommen... Nur mal für die, die jetzt nicht aus Sachsen sind,
die wissen vielleicht nicht, wer hier regiert hat, die letzte Legislaturperiode.
Aber trotzdem ist es ja umso interessanter, wie orientiert man sich denn da,
weil dann hat man ja auch nicht mehr den Flurfunkvorteil so als neuer Abgeordneter,
sondern man muss sich irgendwie selber in den Strukturen einfinden.
Wir sind am 1.9. an Wahlen.
2019. Am 19.12.2019 haben wir hier in Sachsen den Ministerpräsidenten Michael Kretschmann gewählt.
Da habe ich immer noch heute Probleme mit meiner rechten Hand.
Aber dann wurden im Landtag Ausschüsse gebildet.
Also je nach den einzelnen Ministerien, die quasi in den Koalitionsverhandlungen verteilt wurden.
Und dann habe ich gedacht, jetzt geht es los.
Was für einen Ausschuss bist du gelandet? gewesen. Ich bin im Wirtschafts- und
Verkehrsausschuss und im Energie, Klima, Umwelt, Landwirtschaft.
Wir haben die auch immer AWAS und ECULA genannt, weil die Titel einfach zu lang sind.
Aber ja, das ist vielleicht auch für Menschen nicht aus Sachsen irrelevant.
Genau, dann war Pandemie. Dann war nichts mehr mit Landtag. Dann war nichts
mit Kollegen kennenlernen, die ich ja noch nicht kannte.
Also die Grünen schon, aber in der Koalition hatte ich ja nur in den Koalitionskommissionen.
Verhandlungen gesehen und war dann schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Dann gab es auch noch diese ganze Infrastruktur mit dem Zoom und Jitsi und BigBlueButton
noch nicht und ja, dann mussten sich so die Ausschüsse ein bisschen eingrooven.
Man hat es auch in Sachsen nicht geschafft, ich glaube in anderen Ländern hat
man das geschafft, dass man virtuelle Ausschusssitzungen machen kann und dass
man nicht viajahr fahren muss, was immer so ein bisschen fragwürdig fahren im Zug und so weiter.
Und wir hatten noch eine Sondersitzung im Messesaal, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war auch ganz besonders, da haben wir noch einen Nachtragshaushalt beschlossen
und wir hatten selbst genähte Corona-Masken, weil es noch keine FFP2-Masken gab.
Und dann hatten wir alle anderthalb Meter Abstand und also absurde Situationen,
die so nicht, Gott sei Dank, ich hoffe, dass die nächsten Leute das nicht noch
mal so durchmachen müssen. Also die Einarbeitungszeit war wild.
Also steile Lernkurve, genau. Okay, und was war das?
Also wir gehen ja immer so ein bisschen darauf ein, wie so ein Gesetzgebungsprozess
auch funktioniert auf Landesebene.
Ich habe mir das mal schon so angeguckt. Ihr seid ja als Landtag für Schule
und Bildung, Hochschulen, Polizei, Versammlungsrecht, Kultur,
Medienpolitik und Kommunales zuständig. soweit, wie ich das verstanden habe.
Und dann gibt es noch einige Überschneidungspunkte mit dem Bund.
Aber die Schritte, wie so ein Gesetzgebungsprozess dann startet,
ist ja, ich sag mal, vom Ablauf relativ ähnlich wie fleißige Zuhörende auch
aus anderen Parlamenten das kennen.
Gibt es irgendwie ein digital politisches Gesetz,
was du mit auf den Weg gebracht hast, was wir jetzt mal so als Beispiel durchexcessieren
können oder was du begleitet hast, das muss nicht von dir kommen,
um mal zu erklären, wie so ein Gesetzgebungsprozess eigentlich abläuft?
Also es gibt in Sachsen quasi das, wenn ich jetzt so auf die Digitalpolitik
gucke, fällt mir jetzt spontan das E-Government-Gesetz ein, was sozusagen den
Austausch innerhalb der Behörden, also den digitalen Austausch innerhalb der
Behörden und alles, was da so dran hängt, regelt.
Da steht tatsächlich im Gesetz, dass wir das novellieren müssten.
Da haben sie aber in dieser Legislatur nicht geschafft. Also von daher ist das
ein schlechtes Beispiel.
Dann nimm doch das Transparenzgesetz. Genau, darauf wäre ich jetzt als zweite Option geschwenkt.
Und wir nehmen das Transparenzgesetz als Beispiel.
Vielleicht nochmal, was ist das überhaupt, bevor wir jetzt irgendwie in den Prozess gehen?
Ich weiß nicht, der eine oder andere kennt vielleicht die kleine Schwester,
das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Also der Staat muss auf Anfrage von Netzpolitik oder einzelnen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern bestimmte Informationen, solange sie nicht irgendwelchen sicherheitsrelevanten Sachen usw.
Widersprechen, veröffentlichen. Ein Transparenzgesetz geht quasi nochmal einen
Schritt weiter und... Nee, gerade nicht veröffentlichen, sondern herausgeben.
Das Transparenzgesetz ist ja genau... Und ein Transparenzgesetz würde eine Regierung
dazu verpflichten, von sich aus diese Informationen der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und dieser Prozess würde jetzt, wir gehen jetzt mal vom Regelfall aus,
es gibt ja auch noch so Sonderfälle, dass irgendwie eine Fraktion oder der Landtag...
Das ist voll, glaube ich auch. Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit,
haben wir übrigens auch in Sachsen gemacht.
Ein Gesetz zur Gemeinschaftsschule erfolgreich hier eingebracht wurden und dann
von den Koalitionsfaktoren beschlossen.
Aber zurück zum Transparenzgesetz.
Es gibt auf, wir haben ja hier sozusagen in Dresden die Regierungsseite und
die Landtagsseite getrennt von der Corolla-Brücke.
Entschuldigung, Berlin. Das sollten wir jetzt kurz erklären.
Wir sind im September 2024 für die Hörer, die das 2031 hören.
Und die Carola-Brücke in Dresden ist gerade zusammengekracht und ist jetzt ein
touristisches Monument geworden. Ja, also in der Regel gibt es einen Prozess,
der wird auf Regierungsseite angestoßen.
Da setzen sich die Fachreferenten in den Ministerien hin und schreiben einen
Referentenentwurf eben für dieses Transparenzgesetz.
In unserem Fall in Sachsen ist das Justizministerium auch unter grüner Leitung
von Katja Mayer dafür verantwortlich gewesen.
Und dann gibt es einen, sobald es diesen Referentenentwurf gibt,
wird er dann in die Ressortabstimmung gegeben, also innerhalb der verschiedenen
von dem Gesetz betroffenen Ministerien verteilt.
Dann gibt es eine oder zwei Feedback-Schleifen in dem Fall des Transparenzgesetzes.
Da habe ich mal was von knapp an vierstelliger Zahl an Änderungswünschen gehört.
Also man hat das schon versucht.
Darf ich dazu was fragen? Wie schlimm sind bei euch die Änderungsanträge, Tabellen?
Wie schlimm? Ist das auch so, wie man das kennt von der EU, dass man dann so
ein Dokument kriegt? Ich weiß nicht, wir haben da glaube ich schon mal drüber
geredet in irgendeiner Sendung.
Also so solche, wenn du sagst eine vierstellige Zahl, das ist wirklich krass.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn man das verfolgen muss, da gibt es dann so Spalten-Dokumente,
wo das dann von jedem Vorschlag abzulesen ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist das bei euch genau der gleiche Kram. Ich kenne jetzt die
Dokumente aus der EU nur bedingt, also von daher kann ich das jetzt nicht genau sagen.
Bin auch nicht in dieser Konsultation auf Regierungsebene involviert gewesen
als Landtagsabgeordneter, von daher kann ich das nicht sagen.
Aber was ich sagen kann, also diese hohe Anzahl an Änderungswünschen,
die natürlich alle gesagt haben, dass wir dem Transparenzgesetz,
das ist eine ganz schwierige Kiste und das können wir nicht machen.
Und der ganze Sprechstatt bricht zusammen und wir müssen das irgendwie verhindern.
Das Abendland geht unter und so weiter.
Das war alles sozusagen politisch, also nicht alles, aber ein Großteil davon
war irgendwie politisch inszeniert, um das halt zu verhindern,
was nicht geschafft wurde.
Wir haben am Ende ein Transparenzgesetz geschaffen in einer Koalition mit einem
sehr konservativen CDU-Landesverband,
was im Ranking von Frag den Staat ein mittleres, ich weiß nicht genau,
Platz 8 oder so bekommen hat. Also, dass wir da jetzt nicht,
das Paradebeispiel für ein Transparenzgesetz in Sachsen auf die Beine stellen
können, das war von vornherein klar.
Aber mit dem, was rausgekommen ist, bin ich sehr zufrieden, ist unsere Landratsfraktion
und das Ministerium auch sehr zufrieden.
Und vielleicht darf ich den einen Punkt an der Stelle machen,
ein bisschen das Verfahren verlassen.
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, du hast ganz schnell vorgespult dann. Entschuldigung.
Aber mach den einen Punkt gerne noch und dann spulen wir wieder zurück.
Backtracking können Ja, ich dachte, ich gehe vielleicht, also ich glaube auf
den IT-Kern dieses Gesetzes nochmal ein, weil mir das jetzt besonders wichtig war.
Also das Gesetz regelt natürlich, wer was irgendwie wo veröffentlichen muss,
aber es gibt auch einen Paragrafen da drin zur sogenannten Transparenz-Plattform.
Also das ist quasi die Software, auf der dann tatsächlich die Informationen
veröffentlicht werden. Also ich gehe davon aus, dass es automatisch passiert.
Und wir haben es jetzt in den Verhandlungen geschafft, dass diese Plattform,
so wie das auch in anderen Bundesländern der Fall ist, als Open Source Software
wird die entwickelt und basierend auf Open Source Software.
Okay, das war jetzt sozusagen der Fast Forward. Wir gehen jetzt noch mal ein paar Schritte zurück.
Also du hast gerade gesagt, die Initiative kam von der Regierung.
Da wurden dann Schleifen gedreht in den Ministerien und normalerweise ist es
ja dann so, dass man das beim Landtagspräsidenten oder Präsidentin,
ich weiß es gar nicht, ich glaube, Thüringen hat eine Präsidentin gehabt.
Eine Vizepräsidentin. Vielleicht habe ich es auch gerade verwechselt.
Genau, dass man es dort einreicht und dann geht es ja als nächstes in die Ausschussarbeit,
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und dann hat es einen von deinen beiden Ausschüssen betroffen?
Wahrscheinlich ja nicht. Fangen wir mal bei der Ressortabstimmung an,
wenn quasi alle Änderungswünsche aus den einzelnen Ressorts,
also aus den einzelnen Ministerien,
irgendwann zur Zufriedenheit der einzelnen Ministerien bearbeitet wurden,
so dass die keine Einwände mehr haben oder sich nicht hinreichend wehren können
gegen bestimmte Erwiderungen,
dann gibt es das Kabinett, in dem dann eine,
einstimmige Entscheidung dazu getroffen wird, dass die Regierungskoalition das Gesetz so annimmt.
Und dann wird das Gesetz überstellt, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich über den
Postweg an den Sächsischen Landtag.
Da wird es wieder digitalisiert, in unser Parlamentsinformationssystem eingescannt.
Naja, ich übertreibe es auch ein bisschen, aber an manchen Stellen ist es teilweise schon so.
Gerade was Kleine Anfragen angeht oder sowas, da gibt es immer wieder Medienbrüche.
Und dann wird dieses Gesetz in den Justizausschuss verwiesen,
in dem ich nicht Mitglied bin, Aber immer gelegentlich, gerade was diese Transparenz-Plattformen
angeht, hier und da mal Feedback geben durfte, wie man das.
Im Bundestag ist es ja üblich, aber nicht in allen Gesetzgebungsprozessen,
aber doch üblich, eine Sachverständigenanhörung zu haben.
War das hier im Justizausschuss auch so? Das war ja auch so, genau.
Also wir haben, wie soll ich sagen.
Vielleicht auch da vorgeschaltet noch innerhalb der Koalition nochmal,
also innerhalb der drei Regierungsfraktionen auch intern nochmal Verhandlungsrunden
gehabt, wo man sich darauf geeinigt hat, welche Dinge die Regierungskoalition nochmal ändern möchte.
Das ist quasi nicht in diesen öffentlichen Sitzungen im Landtag stattgefunden.
Aber die Sachverständigenanhörung, die, also wie ich finde, noch mit das,
also wirklich eines der lehrreichsten Instrumente in dieser Parlamentsarbeit war.
Also ich habe das immer sehr, sehr gerne gemacht. Man hat für die Leute,
die das nicht kennen, wir haben die, bei uns läuft das so ab,
dass wir... Wir müssen jetzt spoilern, die Folge dicke Bresse vor dieser geht
um Sachverständigenanhörung.
Insofern verweisen wir auf die Folge. Aber ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen dann. Go ahead.
Okay, also bei uns läuft das so, aber wir haben den sogenannten kleinen Schlüssel,
dann kann die CDU vier Leute senden, die AfD kann glaube ich auch vier.
Vier Sachverständige? Vier. Oh, das ist voll bei euch in den Ausschüssen, ja?
Siehst du, die Seite haben wir noch nicht beleuchtet, das ist jetzt vielleicht mal ganz interessant.
Wir haben also zehn, warte mal, vielleicht habe ich auch Quatsch,
nee, vier die CDU, drei die AfD und dann linke, grüne, SPD jeweils ein.
Und das macht zehn insgesamt, genau. Wow.
Da kommen ja noch die Institutionellen dazu. Ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich den
Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten, der ja auch für Informationsfreiheit kommt, oder?
Nicht in den Ausschüssen, in denen ich Sachverständigenanhörungen gemacht habe,
muss auch gestehen, ich habe das einmal erlebt, dass wirklich zehn Leute da waren.
Ach wie, die kommen nicht, wenn man die einlädt?
Die benennen wahrscheinlich nicht mehr. Naja, also ich persönlich hätte gern
mehr Leute eingeladen, aber ich habe ja nur Vorschlagsrecht für eine Person.
Ich habe auch hier und da mal Listen aufgestellt und die anderen Fraktionen,
die in der Regierungskoalition mehr Leute einladen können, zur Verfügung gestellt.
Das hat manchmal funktioniert, das hat manchmal nicht funktioniert.
Je nachdem, welche politische Ausrichtung vielleicht auch diese Leute da haben.
Ja, also ich habe ganz viele Klimasachen auch angehört und dann werden also
entweder gar keine Menschen von konservativen oder rechtsradikalen Parteien
geladen oder ganz wenige.
Und dann gibt es auch mal so verschiedene Anhörungen mit vier Personen.
Ich werde mal nochmal grundsätzlich fragen. Im Bundestag ist mein Eindruck sehr
häufig, wir haben in der Folge davor darüber schon mal gesprochen und da würde
ich gerne deinen Eindruck hören. Du hast es ja eben beschrieben,
also vom Referentenentwurf über die Ressortabstimmung, dann nochmal eine Runde
in der eigenen Koalition.
Wie doll will man dann eigentlich noch externe Sachverständige haben,
die einem vielleicht sogar noch Sachen rausreichen oder ändern lassen wollen,
obwohl man nun schon den langen Vorlauf hatte?
Also will man eigentlich wirklich hören, was Experten dazu sagen und ändern?
Oder möchte man es dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen durchkriegen?
Das ist jetzt eher eine allgemeine Frage und nicht unbedingt speziell für Transparenzgrenze
gemeint. Wir bestehen auf ähnlichen Antworten.
Wir sind ja am Beispiel Transparenzgesetz und da hat beispielsweise,
ich mache auch einen kleinen Werbeblock, dass die Sachverständigenaussage von
der GFF, also der Gesellschaft für Freieißrechte, schon nochmal Dinge zum Positive verändert.
Du musst dann bedenken, die Antwort ja ja im Prinzip. Dann will man tatsächlich werden.
Natürlich will ich Sachverständige hören. Ich hatte ja in dem ganzen Prozess
der Gesetzgebung bisher noch überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, externe Sachverständige
zu diesem Gesetzentwurf zu hören.
Und das war ja alles sozusagen Regierungsseite und da bin ich nicht dabei.
Und von daher ist das meine Gelegenheit, da nochmal externen Sachverstand drauf zu geben.
Und das ist doch, wie gesagt, zehn maximal. Aber wenn man jetzt irgendwie sieben
Leute hat, die im Regelfall aus sieben verschiedenen Perspektiven auf einen
Gesetzentwurf gucken, dann kriegt man schon ein ziemlich gutes Bild.
Ich finde das gut. Mich freut es, weil im Bundestag oft mein Eindruck ist,
dass das nicht mehr der Fall ist.
Weil der koalitionsinterne Streit oft schon so lange gärt, dass ich manchmal
zumindest den Eindruck habe, dass die Sachverständigen eine reine Demokratieübung
und letztlich eine Demokratie-Simulation abgeben. Aber wenn es im Landtag nicht
so ist, würde mich das eher freuen.
Meine Erfahrung ist halt oft im Bundestag und da läuft es leider oft nicht so.
Insofern ist es sehr erfreulich. Man muss ja auch prozessual sagen,
diese Anhörung findet ja statt,
bevor ihr im EU-Parlament eure Opinion als Ausschuss abgegeben habt.
Also deswegen ist das ja wahrscheinlich eher hilfreich, um eure Debatte noch
weiter zu führen. Wir haben im Vorfeld quasi unsere Änderungswünsche.
Und dann, die haben wir sicherlich auch schon mal ausgetauscht in der Runde
der Koalition und dann gibt es die Anhörung und danach sagt man,
ja, aber drei von sieben Sachverständigen haben gesagt, das ist eine gute Idee.
Und dann hat man natürlich nochmal das Argument, dass das jetzt eine gute Idee ist.
Und wenn man dann natürlich den konservativen Sachverständigen hat,
der dann das sagt, was man selber gefordert hat, dann ist das natürlich umso
mehr Überzeugungsarbeit innerhalb der Koalition.
Alles klar. Okay, also wir haben die Sachverständigenanhörung gemacht und dann
geht es wieder zurück in den Ausschuss.
Und was passiert dann als nächstes? Wenn man dann Änderungen machen möchte.
Dann muss man da ja für einen Änderungsantrag am Gesetz vornehmen und das sind natürlich,
also diese ganze Fraktion und diese ganze Landtagsarbeit ist unglaublich formal,
unglaublich hierarchisch strukturiert und es gibt ganz viele Fristen,
die man irgendwie einhalten muss.
So einen Änderungsantrag an einem Gesetz, den muss man halt irgendwie,
sag ich mal, wenn er jetzt halt gut läuft und nicht politisch.
Blockiert wird von verschiedenen Seiten, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, ein halbes Jahr.
Also wenn es gut ist. Man muss innerhalb der Arbeitskreise der Fraktionen,
also jede einzelne Fraktion hat Arbeitskreise, die sich mit bestimmten Themen
beschäftigen, die müssen zustimmen.
Dann muss man diese drei Arbeitskreise aus den drei Fraktionen müssen irgendwie
das als eine gute Idee empfinden. Dann geht es in die Fraktionssitzungen der einzelnen Fraktionen.
Und irgendwann kommt man mal dazu, dass man einen Änderungsantrag hat,
dem alle innerhalb der Koalition zugestimmt haben.
Und das je nach Frist. Also man trifft sich zu Fraktionssitzungen.
Ich glaube, die CDU trifft sich einmal im Monat zu Fraktionssitzungen.
Und wenn man da irgendwie mal so sagt, ja, wir hatten keine Zeit für euren Änderungsantrag,
dann vergeht halt mal einen Monat. Dann sind Ferien.
Also in Ferien passiert sowieso nichts.
Also es gibt so viele Ferien. So ein bisschen wie Schule, also nur,
dass ihr wirklich Feier habt.
Man hat gerade wieder irgendwie Fahrt aufgenommen, Ferien. Und dann geht es um Ferien.
Also es war ein bisschen frustrierend, gerade wenn man da irgendwie ein bisschen
mehr Arbeit rein investiert in sein politisches Engagement, dann sind diese
Ferien, ich gönne die jedem.
Aber wir waren schon an der einen oder anderen Stelle ein bisschen hinderlich,
weil dann ist auch niemand erreichbar und alle Büros nicht besetzt.
Und Abstimmungen kann man sowieso nicht machen, weil die müssen ja immer alle
da sein. Aber wenn man dann den Änderungsantrag in den drei Fraktionen beschlossen
hat, dann geht der nochmal in den Ausschuss, wird im Ausschuss nochmal besprochen.
Die Koalitionsfraktionen stimmen mit Mehrheit im Ausschuss dem Änderungsantrag
zu und dann wird da vorgemerkt für das nächste Plenum,
in dem das Gesetz nochmal zur Aussprache steht und dann je nach Größe Änderungsanträge
zum Gesetz besprochen werden.
Und dann kommt der Punkt, wo dann wirklich alle 119 oder 120 Abgeordnete im
Landtag sitzen und dann entweder Ja, Nein oder Inhaltung sagen.
Dann eine ganz kurze Zwischenfrage. Das klingt jetzt super langwierig und noch
nerviger als auf der EU-Ebene.
Wie ist das denn als zivilgesellschaftliche Akteurin?
Wann ist ein guter Zeitpunkt, also außer wenn man benannt wird für die Sachverständigenanhörung,
sich einzubringen, um gehört zu werden, um
Einfluss zu nehmen auf solche Gesetzgebungsprozesse? So früh wie möglich.
Also ich würde da jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht darauf warten,
bis ich irgendwie höre, dass die Regierung einen Gesetzentwurf entwickelt.
Ich würde trotzdem, ich würde sofort mit meinem Anliegen an meinen Abgeordneten
des Sächsischen Landtags treten, also auf Landesebene.
Da kann man ja versuchen, Termine mit den Landtagsabgeordneten zu organisieren.
Ich glaube, an die Fraktionsvorsitzende wird man jetzt nicht direkt kommen, vermute ich mal.
Aber wenn man sich da so langsam hocharbeitet und eskaliert, kann man das schon.
Also bei mir kriegt man Termine auf jeden Fall. Moment, ihr habt erst recht.
Nun ist ja das Transparenzgesetz nicht in Sachsen erfunden worden.
Das heißt, man hat Vorläufer in anderen Bundesländern und verschiedene Erfahrungen.
Inwieweit ist denn in diesem ganzen Prozess, wenn wir jetzt schon das Beispiel
vom Transparenzgesetz haben, irgendwie eine Erfahrung aus anderen Ländern,
egal ob sie jetzt positiv, ich meine Bundesländer natürlich,
positiv oder negativ war, eingeflossen.
Inwieweit hat man sich zum Beispiel mit anderen Ministerien oder auch mit Praktikern
auseinandergesetzt, die anderswo bereits ein angewandtes Transparenzgesetz haben? Sehr intensiv.
Also das habe ich als Landesabgeordneter war ich in diesem Prozess nicht direkt
involviert, aber ich habe es immer wieder mitbekommen.
Da gab es einen sehr intensiven Austausch mit anderen Bundesländern.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, welche NRW, Hamburg, glaube ich,
müssten es gewesen sein.
Da wurde nachgefragt, welche Software verwendet ihr?
Habt ihr die angepasst? Wie viele Mannstunden oder Fraustunden gehen in die
Beantwortung der Anfragen?
Also gerade der Kostenfaktor wurde von unseren Koalitionspartnern sehr intensiv
bearbeitet. Ah, apropos Koalitionspartner.
Wie fand denn dein Fastparteifreund Armin Schuster die Idee? War der da schon im Amt?
Kein Ausweichen, wir brauchen da eine Antwort. Du musst kurz erklären, wer Armin Schuster ist.
Armin Schuster ist der sächsische Innenminister, der quasi in der Mitte der
Legislatur ungefähr für Armin Wöller eingewechselt wurde,
um vielleicht im Fußball-Sprech zu bleiben oder überhaupt zu benutzen.
Wir sind ja noch gar nicht da.
Ich kann ja nicht sagen, ob der vorher oder nachher da war.
Wir kennen die Einschätzung jetzt von Armin Schuster. Wir hören,
dass der Innenminister hier offenbar nicht weiter involviert war. Sehr überraschend.
Ich glaube, man war sehr froh, dass das Justizministerium da an der Stelle die
Hand gehoben hat und sich darum kümmern möchte.
Und dann war das auch, wir schieben die Arbeit zu denen, machen die,
machen ihnen die Arbeit so schwer wie möglich und dann gucken wir,
was passiert und wie gesagt, jetzt haben wir eins, was.
Zumindest den Namen verdient. Kann man immer noch besser machen.
Wir wollten gerne, dass das Transparenzgesetz auch für sächsische Kommunen gilt,
dass die auch Dinge veröffentlichen müssen.
Das war schon in den Koalitionsverhandlungen quasi ausgeschlossen worden, dass das so geht.
Das hatten wir jetzt noch natürlich mit unserem Wahlprogramm aufgenommen.
Aber nur jetzt sieht es ja wahrscheinlich so aus, dass hier keine grüne Beteiligung
in der nächsten sächsischen Welt. Es ist leider in anderen Bundesländern auch
so, dass die Kommunen sich relativ stark und auch erfolgreich werden.
Ja, du hast, also eigentlich haben wir es jetzt einmal sozusagen gut durchdekliniert
und wir sind ja gerade schon so ein bisschen auf die neue politische Lage zu sprechen gekommen.
Und vielleicht ist das auch mal eine ganz gute Überleitung, denn wir haben jetzt
ja, ich sag mal, eine bedrückende Auswahl der Wahlen.
Und jetzt wollen wir mal so ein bisschen darüber sprechen,
was hat sich zum einen digitalpolitisch getan in der Legislatur,
in der du sozusagen dabei warst, aber auch, was ist irgendwie zu erwarten oder
wie sind so deine Erfahrungen,
was so wichtige Themen sind in der Digital- und Netzpolitik auf Landesebene?
Das ist eine ganz große Frage.
Ja, das ist der Podcast hier für die ganz großen Fragen und die ganz dicken Bretter.
Fünf Jahre Landtagsarbeit in zwei Sätze.
Oder vielleicht anders gefragt, siehst du durch, also was auch immer da jetzt
dann koalitionstechnisch auf uns zukommt, Momente, die Sachen rückgängig machen
könnten, die ihr euch erkämpft habt?
Vielleicht fangen wir mal an, wie die nächste Legislatur sein könnte.
Ich habe ja auch keine Glaskugel.
Und dann können wir ja auf die einzelnen Sachen, die jetzt in der bestehenden
Legislatur passiert sind, nochmal eingehen.
Also die Wahlergebnisse, die hier entstanden sind am 1.
September, lassen eigentlich aktuell von den Dingen, die ausgeschlossen wurden
und mit der AfD will ja sowieso Gott sei Dank niemand koalieren.
Nur eine Koalition zu und das ist CDU, PSW und SPD.
Also CDU und SPD kann ich ungefähr einschätzen.
Wie sie handeln werden, was das BSW im Bereich alles macht, ist mir völlig unbekannt.
Warte, hast du da nicht nachgeguckt?
Ja, ich hatte heute Morgen große Langeweile und dann habe ich mal geguckt,
wie häufig die Worte digital in den unterschiedlichen Wahlprogrammen vorkommen.
Also zumindest bei den Parteien, die, sage ich mal, potenziell in der Regierung sein konnten.
Und das Interessante ist, wenn es eine Koalition mit CDU und BSW gibt,
dann ich glaube, die kommen sich gar nicht so krass in die Queren,
außer vielleicht im Thema Bildung und Digitalisierung.
Die CDU hat 63 Mal das Wort digital in ihrem Wahlprogramm und nicht viel überraschen.
Natürlich irgendwie digitale Räume heißt, es sollten keine Toleranzräume für Kriminalität sein.
Wir wissen alle, was das heißt. Staatstrojaner, mehr Überwachung für alle.
Und ansonsten ist es eher so mehr Digitalisierung für alles Mögliche,
Justiz, Verbraucherschutz,
Unternehmen, Transformation, Bildung, natürlich Asylverfahren.
Das BSW hat das Wort digital nur 16 Mal. Zum Vergleich, die AfD hat 13 Mal das
Wort digital in ihrem Wahlprogramm.
Und das BSW legt einen sehr großen Schwerpunkt auf das Recht auf analog.
Die sind sehr dagegen,
dass es irgendwelche Digitalisierungsprojekte in Schulen gibt
und also eigentlich wollen sie Schuldigitalisierung stoppen und ansonsten konzentrieren
sie sich auf Vereinfachung von Prozessen durch Verwaltungsdigitalisierung und
Innovationen im Bereich von Pflege zum Beispiel, um den Fachkräftemangel zu.
Um dem Fachkräftemangel entgegenzuwirken. Also das vielleicht zu den beiden.
Und die AfD möchte Schuldigitalisierung erst ab der vierten Klasse.
Die haben sich da einfach eine Altersgrenze überlegt. Und was ich besonders
interessant habe bei der AfD, das ist eigentlich eher ein CDU-Wort,
Technologieoffenheit ist auch ein Term, der sehr häufig herkommt.
Sieht ja jetzt so aus, da wird ja mit der AfD erstmal niemand koalieren.
Und die Frage, die du jetzt gerade anreißen wolltest, war ja,
was könnten die zurückdrehen?
Und da ist ja vielleicht, zumindest von dem, was du jetzt erwähnt hast,
nicht wirklich was dabei, wo du das befürchten müsstest. Oder befürchtest du
das bei irgendwas Konkretem?
Ich würde erst mal sagen, bei den Sachen, die wir jetzt in den letzten Jahren
gemacht haben, die sind, glaube ich,
ich erwarte da jetzt nicht, dass man das, also zumindest in den Teilen,
in denen ich zuständig war, habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass man da jetzt irgendwas zurückdrehen wird.
Bildung bin ich nicht so nah dran, kann ich dir nicht so genau beantworten.
Gut möglich, dass man bestimmte Dinge da irgendwie als rote Linie in Koalitionsverhandlungen
bringt. Ob das so passiert ist, weiß ich nicht.
Ich kann mir auch diese ganze Diskussion ums BSW, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
wie ein CDU-Landesverband Sachsen mit einer Partei, die aus Postkommunisten
zusammengesetzt wurde, koaliert.
Das ist mir unbegreiflich. Die haben mit der Linken quasi einen Unfalleinbarkeitsbeschluss
getroffen, dass sie nicht zusammenarbeiten.
Wir hatten das hier und da in Sachsen auch ein Problem, beziehungsweise mussten
auch zusammenarbeiten bei Dingen, wo eine Zweidrittelmehrheit notwendig ist.
Da musste das passieren.
Da ist man darüber in den Schatten gesprungen. Aber wie man quasi den kommunistischen
Teil aus der Linken rausnimmt und mit dem dann anfängt zu koalieren.
Okay, aber heißt das ganz praktisch gesehen, wenn ihr die Fristen im Landtag
nicht schafft für die Wahl eines Ministerpräsidenten und letztlich die Aufstellung
einer Regierung, würde dann praktisch bedeuten, dass du Neuwahlen nicht für
unwahrscheinlich hältst. Ist das richtig?
Ja, dem würde ich so zustimmen. Ich habe, also die Wahlergebnisse sind nicht stabil.
Ich behaupte, also Michael Kretschmer hat das auch, also man kann das auch gut
beobachten, dass es quasi mit der Bundestagswahl ist in Sachsen hier irgendwie
bei der CDU der Schalter umgefallen und ab dem ging es die ganze Zeit los.
Dass Grüne sind daran schuld, dass die Energiepreise so hoch sind,
Grüne sind daran schuld, dass dein Schnurrenkel offen ist und so weiter.
Man hat das jahrelang quasi allen eingetrichtert und damit hat man auch als
CDU-Ministerpräsident gegen den eigenen Koalitionspartner geschossen, aber okay,
das ist vielleicht das politische Spiel, aber man hat sich auch die Möglichkeit
verbaut, Eine Regierungskoalition, die vielleicht einen schlechten Ruf hatte,
aber ich finde trotzdem viele Dinge über die letzten fünf Jahre ordentlich im Sinne von,
naja, keine Ahnung, wir haben 119 Gesetze in Sachsen beschlossen und was weiß
ich, wie viele Anträge noch und sonstige Dinge im Doppelhaushalt irgendwie Geld
ausgegeben. Das hat alles irgendwie funktioniert.
Ich glaube, der Unterschied ist vielleicht auch einfach, dass man das noch halbwegs
zivilisiert konnte, ohne sich gegenseitig permanent zu diffamieren, zu beschimpfen.
Das war ja auch mit einer Form von Sacha.
Okay, ihr habt auch geschimpft. Ich habe immer nur Armin Schuster gehört.
Ja, Armin Schuster hat auch geschimpft. Aber weil du jetzt gerade nochmal die
Fristen angesprochen hattest, das vielleicht noch zur Erklärung. Wir haben am 1.9.
Gewählt. Der 8. Sächsische Landtag hat einen Monat Zeit, sich zu konstituieren.
Das wird ausgereizt und findet quasi am 1.10. statt.
Da passiert auch nicht viel, ne? Man trifft sich in der großen Runde,
sagt hier, ich mach das ordentlich und dann geht man wieder.
Und ab diesem Zeitpunkt vom 1.10. hat man vier Monate Zeit, eine Regierung zu bilden.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das jetzt richtig gesagt. Auf jeden Fall ist die deadline dazu am 2.1.
Und das wird ganz schön knapp in der Konstellation. Ob das so geht, wir werden es sehen.
Ich kann es ja auch jetzt nicht genau sagen, ich stecke da nicht drin.
Ich bin sowieso als Nichtraubladauer jetzt nicht mehr so involviert in den ganzen
Gesprächen, die im Landtag stattfinden.
Vielleicht würde ich da noch eine Anschlussfrage stellen. Wir wollen ja nicht
unbedingt bei dem nächsten Landtag so viel bleiben, aber du hast ja bestimmte
Themen betreut in dieser Fraktion.
Weißt du schon, wer deine Themen betreuen wird und ob es da eine inhaltliche Kontinuität gibt?
Oder vielleicht noch genereller gesprochen, ist es üblich, dass sozusagen auch
mit dem Wechsel der Mandatsträger teilweise oder eben auch mit veränderten Mehrerteidnissen
trotzdem eine inhaltliche, in den Parteien inhaltliche Konsistenz ist?
Sozusagen auch Sachen, die du nicht geschafft hast, zum Beispiel an der Legislaturperiode
fortgesetzt werden und so weiter.
Oder kann ich davon nicht unbedingt ausgehen als Wähler? Naja,
wir sind ja gezwungen, uns zu verändern.
Wir sind von zwölf Abgeordneten auf sieben Abgeordnete geschrumpft.
Bestimmte Kompetenzen, ich habe Klima, Energie, Digitalisierung gemacht,
die sind jetzt weg. Die müssen irgendwie umgeändert werden.
Bei der CDU hast du dann den feuerwehrpolitischen Sprecher oder den Weinbaupolitischen Sprecher.
Wählen die auch Könige oder ist das… Ja,
weil zwar hat man das Gefühl.
Sehr ausdifferenziert, wobei wir sieben Leute, zwei davon müssen noch geschäftsführend
Ministerien führen und so weiter.
Das ist schon eine harte Arbeit. Da hat dann jeder plötzlich irgendwie sieben
Themen und dass man dann da sich irgendwie umstrukturieren muss,
irgendwie muss das halt auch gehen. Nur noch mal kurz zur Erklärung.
Die Geschäftsführung der Ministerien entsteht natürlich dadurch,
dass es noch keine neue Regierung gibt. Es ist quasi ein Part-Time-Job oder so.
Ja, das muss man dann auch noch nebenbei erledigen, richtig?
Genau, jetzt hat man das Mandat und das Ministerium.
Heißt okay, das ist bei euch einfach ein personelles Problem,
aber bei anderen ist es natürlich wiederum andersrum.
So funktioniert ja nun mal in der Demokratie, andere haben natürlich jetzt viel
mehr Leute und können sich ausdifferenzieren, nicht wahr?
So ist das ja, genau. Und man ist auch in der Fläche präsent,
auch wenn man mehr Leute in der Fläche hat. Da muss man nochmal die Frustfrage stellen, wenn ich darf.
Wie frustriert ist das?
Skala von 1 bis 10, 11. Ja, nimmt man die Skala von 1 bis 84.000.
Wie ärgerlich ist das denn am Wahlabend? Und letztlich ist es ja auch,
es ist auch ein Teil von deinen Arbeiten, oder? Ich bin jetzt nochmal angetreten, genau.
Schon, aber du warst ja auch am Wahltag da und hast es dir angesehen.
Ja, es ist beschissen. Also sind wir ehrlich. Also klar steht man da.
Man hat sich fünf Jahre engagiert.
Man hat, was weiß ich, ein Transparenzgesetz geschaffen. Man hat irgendwie ein
Beteiligungsgesetz im manneuerbaren Ausbau geschaffen.
Man hat eine Open-Source-Strategie geschaffen. Und was weiß ich,
ein Breitbandausbau oder zumindest maßgeblich beschleunigt. Ja,
so viele Leute gab es nicht, die sich dann mit diesen Themen beschäftigt haben.
Und dann stellt man sich schon die Frage, wird das jetzt alles zugedreht oder
nicht? Was passiert damit?
Kann ich nicht so richtig sagen. Und es war die große Frage,
ob ich mein Regionalbüro verliere,
was wir irgendwie mühselig aufgebaut haben und alle solche Sachen.
Das ist sehr frustrierend so und muss auch...
Keine Ahnung, ich kann da irgendwie nicht so, also ich kann schwer drum herumreden,
aber für die Digitalpolitik in Sachsen war das keine gute Wahl.
Wir hatten, gut, ich bin nicht nochmal angetreten, okay, geschenkt,
aber ich hatte auch, wir hatten das mittlerweile, gerade im Bereich Digitales
fand ich, haben wir dieses furchtbare Wort zu verwenden, ideologiefrei miteinander gesprochen.
Es gab einen konstruktiven Austausch zwischen mir und der Sächsischen Staatskanzlei,
also in Klammern CDU geführt. Das war gut.
Ich hatte in der CDU-Fraktion einen Fürsprecher, der auch bestimmte Dinge mitgetragen hat.
Und der das, keine Ahnung, wenn wir jetzt hier von Open Data oder Open Source
Software sprechen, das ist gar nicht so einfach, das in die CDU-Fraktion zu
transportieren und dafür Mehrheiten innerhalb der CDU-Fraktion zu organisieren.
Also das war schon gut, dass man da zusammengearbeitet hat.
Aber derjenige hat im Erzgebirge leider auch gegen den AfD-Direktkandidaten
verloren, den keiner kennt, der noch nie irgendwie was gemacht hat. Aber so ist das halt.
Genau, also die Menschen, die sich in Sachsen für Digitalisierung und alles,
was da irgendwie so dran hängt, engagiert haben, die werden nicht mehr...
Okay, also wir hören deinen Frust, glaube ich, ziemlich deutlich.
Das ist ja auch total verständlich.
Aber jetzt hast du, während du über den Frust geredet hast, ein paar sehr konkrete
Projekte angesprochen, die ich irgendwie durchgesetzt habe.
Nur haben wir nicht mehr Zeit, die alle zu besprechen. Aber sag mal ein bisschen was dazu.
Also wie weit hat man denn, oh, Kali, sie hebt schon den Namen. Oh ja.
Bevor wir das machen, würde ich noch fragen, also wir haben ja jetzt darüber
gesprochen, Gesetze zurückzudrehen.
Gibt es auch Sachen, also nachdem so ein Gesetz beschlossen ist, geht es ja weiter.
Das ist ja dann nicht so, dass dann das einfach auf Papier steht und dann ist
es so, sondern das muss ja dann auch noch an vielen Stellen durchgesetzt werden.
Dann bist du denn wenigstens, sage ich mal, bei der Durchsetzung von den Sachen,
die ihr so beschlossen habt, hoffnungsfroh oder hast du das Gefühl,
da könnte auch noch einfach was versanden?
Muss man da auch vielleicht auch als Zivilgesellschaft, die jetzt hier ja natürlich
auch viel anwesend ist, auch nochmal genau hingucken?
Oh, es tut mir leid.
Also man muss auch erst mal ein Gesetz ändern. Also das klingt jetzt irgendwie,
man sagt das so leicht, aber das ist nicht leicht.
Also für irgendwelche bestimmten Dinge Mehrheiten zu organisieren,
da muss man sich schon einig sein.
Ich habe da größere Bedenken, dass das irgendwie in dem digitalpolitischen Raum
glaube ich nicht, wo ich irgendwie mehr Angst und weniger Ahnung habe,
ist der ganze Teil Migration,
ist der Teil Klimapolitik, Energiepolitik, da ist sowieso die Wirtschaft schon
viel, viel weiter als die sächsische Landesregierung.
Aber das sind schon Themen, da frage ich mich jetzt, wer kümmert sich da jetzt
in Zukunft drum? Also CDU sehe ich jetzt nicht.
Eigentlich schließt sich da noch eine Frage an. Also wir haben jetzt so ein
bisschen, war ja der politische Prozess, den da hast du beschrieben.
Aber da ist ja auch noch dieser ganze Teil Öffentlichkeitsarbeit.
Also man muss ja, was man schafft im politischen Raum, muss man ja kommunizieren.
Wie viel Platz in deiner parlamentarischen Arbeit musst du das einnehmen?
Wie gerne hast du die gemacht und woraus bestand diese Arbeit?
Also wie stelle ich mir das praktisch vor? Ich meine, ich weiß,
es gibt hier natürlich lokale Zeitungen, das ist jetzt oft nicht unbedingt ein
überregionales Thema, aber wie läuft das praktisch ab mit der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit,
die ja auch zum politischen Betrieb gehört?
Ja, in der Öffentlichkeitsarbeit gibt es ganz viele verschiedene Sachen, die man da machen muss.
Also relativ regelmäßig gibt es Pressemitteilungen, die man über die Fraktionen veröffentlicht.
Also das ist einfach ein bisschen Text, der quasi per E-Mail an Zeitungsredakteure.
Meistens sind Lokalpresse, manchmal auch Netzpolitik.org, Beispiel zur Corona-Warn-App.
Aber es gibt Fernsehinterviews, die gegeben werden muss. Wir haben Social-Media-Arbeit
ist natürlich eine sehr, also müsste eigentlich noch eine viel größere Rolle
in meiner Arbeit einnehmen, als ich das geschafft habe.
Ich bin jemand, der mehr inhaltlich arbeitet und dann am Ende nicht dazu kommt
oder nicht genug dazu kommt, bestimmte Dinge da auch noch so zu erklären,
dass man sie tatsächlich nach außen hin versteht. Das ist gar nicht so einfach,
wie man vielleicht irgendwie denkt.
Ich habe da auch immer so einen gewissen Anspruch an die Kommunikation.
Ich will irgendwie nicht zu krass verkürzen und irgendwelche Dinge verdrehen.
Das macht dann Social Media ein bisschen schwerer, wenn man noch weiß,
wie Social Media Plattformen funktionieren.
Und was da an Abgrund und Überwachungskapitalismus und so weiter dran hängt,
hat man natürlich noch ein größeres Problem, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
Dafür gibt es ja zum Glück Leute, die sich damit auskennen. Ich kann also jemanden
beschäftigen, der das dafür hat, Abgeordnete haben ein gewisses Budget,
mit dem sie Leute bezahlen können, die dann, keine Ahnung, fachliche Fragen
machen, Social Media Fragen machen, Orga-Fragen machen und so weiter.
Das ist also sozusagen outsourcbar und dann kriegt man das auch okay.
Okay, das heißt, Nerds sind offenbar nicht so unbedingt diejenigen,
die auf den Busch klopfen, aber das gibt es ja nur bei Ihnen.
Ja, ich bin Informatiker, also
wenn ich jetzt nicht auf meine Füße gucke beim Reden, ist es ja schon.
Insofern, wir können das nachvollziehen, hier sitzen ja quasi jetzt drei Informatiker.
Aber gut, letztlich ist es aber schon, also zur Politik gehört auch das Verkaufen.
Natürlich, du musst, auch wenn dir ein Ding nicht gefällt, dann muss das,
also dann sollte man das schon jetzt als, oder zumindest die positiven Seiten
daran rauskehren, die man.
Ermöglicht hat und die es ohne dich nicht gegeben hätte. Das gehört schon dazu natürlich.
Okay, also jetzt haben wir, ich weiß nicht, ob ich zu meiner ursprünglichen
Frage zurückkehren darf und Kallise mich böse angucken.
Also, okay, du hast ein paar Beispiele genannt, die du als erfolgreiche Koalitionsarbeit
letztlich und auch Teil deiner erfolgreichen Arbeit bezeichnest.
Nun können wir vielleicht nicht auf alle eingehen, aber du kannst dir eins von
denen rausgreifen, das ist ein Breitband, das ist ein Open Source.
Wo du gerne ein bisschen näher drauf eingehen würdest, wo du sagen würdest,
da habe ich Hartz für gekämpft, das ist ein Erfolg und Baum ist ein Erfolg.
Und es hat Impact auch noch über deinen Legislaturperiode hinaus.
Ich sage drei Sachen so und dann eins im Detail.
Also es gibt einen Punkt, den auch allen Menschen hier im Raum und die in Sachsen unterwegs sind.
Ich möchte euch den Sächsischen Digitalpreis ans Herz legen.
Den habe ich gegründet und den haben auch die Kollegen aus der Dezentrale aus
Leipzig mit ihrem Hardware for Future. Das ist der Leipziger Ableger des Chaos
Computer Clubs. Wer die Dezentrale nicht kennt, muss unbedingt mal hin.
Genau. Und es gibt da drei Tracks.
Gesellschaft, Wirtschaft und Open Source kann man da Preise gewinnen.
Also sehr, sehr coole Geschichte und schafft Öffentlichkeitsarbeit.
Breitbandausbau war ein sehr, sehr, sehr großes Thema in der Legislatur,
auch über die gesamte Legislatur hinweg.
Da gibt es Fördeprogramme vom Bund, die vom Land kofinanziert werden.
Und das war, also gerade diese Gelddiskussion war immer eine große,
weil immer, wenn irgendjemand Geld haben will, fehlt es irgendjemand anders.
Also man könnte, da muss man irgendwie gucken, kriegt man genug Geld für die
Schulen oder für die Bekämpfung des Klimawandels und auch für den Breitbandausbau.
Auf jeden Fall sind das sehr, sehr große Summen, die in den Breitbandausbau
gehen. Wir haben auch versucht, das sozusagen nicht nur mit Geld zu erschlagen.
Mir war das auch besonders wichtig, dass man in diese Verfahren rangeht,
dass man die einzelnen Bauämter irgendwie mal dazu befähigt,
vielleicht auch irgendwie moderne Verlegemethoden zu verwenden.
Dass es Leitfäden gibt, an die sich Leute halten, die solche Verfahren genehmigen und so weiter.
Also dass man wirklich darüber nachdenkt, wie dieser Prozess beschleunigt wird
und dass man nicht irgendwie alles versucht, irgendwie mit Geld zuzuwerfen und
dann wird es schon klappen bis 2030, dass wir dann 100 Prozent mit dem Glasfauhaus ausbauen.
Transparenzgesetz hat man schon gesagt.
Open Source und Open Data? Noch so einen Schwerpunkt von dir? Open Data.
Wir haben innerhalb der Regierungskoalition sehr, sehr viel,
auch in den letzten Zügen dieser Koalition vor der Sommerpause an einem Open-Data-Antrag gefeilt.
Es ging um, dass wir in Sachsen eine Datenökonomie schaffen wollten,
dass wir ein bisschen progressiver an diese Sache rangehen und mehr Open-Data
im Open-Data-Portal zur Verfügung gestellt sind.
Die Ministerien Open-Data-Beauftragte kriegen, die man als Zivilgesellschaft
vielleicht auch ansprechen kann und so weiter.
Es war alles geeint und dann kam der Spruch, das ist leider zu nah am Wahltermin.
Also nein, es wurde nicht so direkt ausgedrückt. Aber wenn man zwischen den
Zeilen lesen kann, ist das die Botschaft.
Was damit passiert, kann ich noch nicht sagen. Wird sich jetzt irgendwie zeigen.
Open Source sieht es besser aus. Open Source sieht es sehr gut aus.
Das ist eine Sache, die habe ich angefangen.
Also das geht weit zurück. Das geht quasi bis zum Koalitionsvertrag 2019 zurück.
Da habe ich das rein verhandelt und diesen Anker haben wir quasi während der
Legislatur genutzt. Und es ist ja auch, in dem Koalitionsvertrag stehen tausende Sachen drin.
Tausende sind ein bisschen übertrieben, aber da sind schon sehr,
sehr viele Einzelpunkte drin.
Und bloß, weil es im Koalitionsvertrag steht, heißt es ja nicht,
dass es irgendwie tatsächlich auch passiert.
Und wir haben aber, das kam aus der Grünen-Fraktion, beziehungsweise von mir
dann die Initiative, das geschafft,
dass es einen Antrag in der Koalition im Sächsischen Landtag gab,
wo drinsteht, ja die Sächsische Staatsregierung
möge bitte sich eine Open-Source-Affaires-Strategie erstellen.
Und dann haben wir das noch ein bisschen qualifiziert mit, da müssen die und
die Personen mit dabei sein, die irgendwie das entwickelt, die gefragt werden,
nur so eine kleine Anhörung machen.
Dann müssen, was ja auch sehr gerne auf Regierungsseite vergessen wird,
Maßnahmen benannt werden, damit man den Erfolg der Umsetzung kontrollieren kann.
Also man stellt ja gerne eine Strategie auf und vermeidet dann,
sich daran messen zu lassen, ob man es jetzt wirklich geschafft hat oder nicht.
Das wurde klar so funktioniert.
Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen Fachverfahren mit, also nicht nur irgendwie,
was weiß ich, Office und Thunderbird und keine Ahnung solche Sachen umstellen,
sondern auch an die einzelnen Fachverfahren gehen.
Und dann gab es einen Beschluss im Sächsischen Landtag.
Oh Gott, ein Jahr später gab es auch die Strategie, die ist öffentlich einsehbar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir die in die Shows packen.
Im Rahmen unserer Recherche haben wir die wohlwollend zur Kenntnis genommen.
Habt ihr auch schon den ersten Bericht?
Ich nicht. In dieser Strategie steht natürlich auch drin, dass die Staatsregierung
regelmäßig über den Erfolg berichten muss. Hast du schon ein Dashboard gebaut?
Nein, ich habe sehr viele Dashboards gebaut. Ich habe ein Corona-Dashboard und
ein Klima-Dashboard gebaut.
Naja, ich dachte, ein Obst-Source-Strategie-Dashboard, das könntest du ja jetzt
machen, wenn du Zeit hast. In diesem Fall noch nicht.
Was steht im ersten Bericht? Also in Menni, jetzt gibt es einen.
Was steht denn drin in dem Bericht?
Das ist übrigens das, was ich mit Durchsetzung meine. Die Gesetze und Strategien
kann man ja schön verabschieden und dann sind sie da.
Aber wir müssen natürlich auch überwachen, ob sie durchgesetzt werden.
Deswegen sind ja solche Berichte eigentlich immer besonders interessant.
Steht denn da auch was drin, was man damit anfangen kann oder ist das so wie
einige Berichte, die wir so auf Bundesebene kennen?
Also ich muss vielleicht noch einen Schritt zurückgehen. Was steht eigentlich
noch in dieser Open-Source-Strategie drin, die die Staatsregierung selber gemacht hat?
Wir wollten damals, als diese Strategie aufgestellt wurde, einen konkreten Umsetzungspfad
haben, wo am Ende Ziele dran stehen. Also Startpunkt, Endpunkt.
Und man hat aber, weil man sich, Digitalisierung ist ein Querschnittsthema,
es gibt keine einzelne Zuständigkeit für die Sachen, es gibt keinen Ausschuss,
der sich wirklich nur auf Digitalisierung beschäftigt im Landtag.
Es gibt kein Digitalministerium, das ist aufgeteilt auf quasi alle Ministerien.
Jeder macht so ein bisschen was, Verwaltungsdigitalisierung ist bei uns in der
Staatskanzlei egal. Und man hatte keinen wirklichen Überblick über alle Ministerien,
welche Software eingesetzt wurde.
Und wenn man keinen Überblick über die eingesetzte Software hat.
Dann kann man verständlicherweise, ich wollte da drastischere Ziele reinkriegen,
aber ich konnte am Ende auch einsehen, dass es irgendwie Schwachsinn ist,
sich Ziele zu setzen, wenn man die Baseline nicht kennt.
Und dann wurde mit der Strategie auch ein, naja, so ein Anhang mit veröffentlicht
und ich empfehle das auch, wenn das jetzt Leute aus anderen Bundesländern hören, da mal reinzugucken.
Das ist tatsächlich eine sinnvolle Sammlung. Also eine Art Bestandsaufnahme, so gemeint? Genau.
Also man hat verschiedene Strategieziele definiert und für die einzelnen Strategieziele,
also wie kriegen wir mehr Open Source, wie kriegen wir irgendwie Akzeptanz in
der Verwaltung und so weiter.
Also es sind sechs Ziele und die stehen da alle da, könnt ihr nachlesen.
Wie kriege ich das gemessen?
Man hat tatsächlich quantitative und qualitative Kriterien aufgestellt,
um zu messen, kommen wir dahin, wo wir wollen oder nicht.
Das ist ja irgendwie aber doch schon irgendwie der Informatikeransatz.
Das ist ja sehr sympathisch eigentlich.
Das finde ich auch sehr sympathisch und ich kann mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht
vorstellen, wie das ohne das gehen soll.
Ich hätte jetzt irgendwie gewünscht, dass diese Daten vielleicht irgendwie schon
vorliegen, dass man sowas strukturiert irgendwo speichert und dass irgendwo
zentral klar ist, welche Software in einem Bundesland verwendet werden.
Vor allen Dingen, welche Lizenzen man eingekauft hat. Scheinbar ist das nicht so.
Und dann hat man sich ein Jahr Zeit gegeben, ausgehend von dieser Strategie,
die wirklich nur abstrakt die Ziele definiert und Handlungsfelder definiert, eine Abfrage.
Innerhalb aller Ministerien zu machen. Also wirklich alle.
Das sind schon eine ganze Reihe an Häusern in Anführungsstrichen.
Und die Unterbehörden dazu und so weiter. Also sozusagen die Struktur der Ministerien.
Es sind am Ende, ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Excel-Tabelle ist oder wahrscheinlich
ist es eine Access-Datenbank, über 6.000 Einträge, die irgendwo gesammelt sind.
Da sind auch doppelte Sachen drin. Aber es ist wirklich eine große Liste an
eingesetzter Software und dazu hat man dann aufgeschrieben, keine Ahnung,
ist das jetzt irgendwie Server, Client und so weiter und so fort und alles irgendwie
so ein paar Kategorien noch dazu geführt.
Welche Lizenz hat das? Also weiß man auch bei vielen Software,
die man gekauft hat, weiß man gar nicht, welche Lizenz das irgendwie hat oder
ob das eine hat. Keine Ahnung.
Das ist ja so IT-Sicherheitsmäßig auch nicht so smart, da keinen Überblick zu
haben. Oh, stehen noch Jahreszahlen dran, so wann beschafft und so?
Wann das letzte Mal abgedechtigt ist es?
Ich habe die Tabelle noch nicht gesehen, ich kann dir das nicht sagen.
Wird die öffentlich sein? Also die komplette Tabelle? Nee, das ist doch bestimmt
irgendwie ein Staatsgeheimnis, oder?
Also wen das interessiert, ich habe mal eine kleine Anfrage gemacht,
welche Software im Landtag oder im Land verwendet wird. Und da kann man das einsehen.
Was man da leider nicht einsehen kann, ist die einzelne Software,
weil das Sicherheitsbedenken und so weiter das verhindert.
Der Bericht, den du jetzt erwähnt hast, der bezieht sich schon auf diese Erhebung sozusagen?
Genau, dieser Bericht ist, also der Landtag hatte die Staatsregierung beauftragt,
auch regelmäßig zu berichten. Und das muss man jetzt irgendwie alle zwei Jahre machen.
Der erste Berichtstermin war jetzt im Juni, Juli und der Bericht ist auch öffentlich.
Können wir ja auch noch verlinken. Verlinken. Und da sind dann Ziele drin,
die ich glaube ich kurz vorlesen muss. Zum Stichtag 30.
Juni 2023 beträgt der Open Source Anteil.
Oh, wie jetzt festhalten. Jetzt konzervaten. Ich habe es leider schon gesehen.
Ich habe es auch jetzt gesehen auf der Bildschirm. 13,5 Prozent zur gesamten
Softwarelandschaft in der sächsischen Staatsverwaltung.
War das mal ein bestimmtes Sollziel prozentual irgendwie?
Das Sollziel kann ich dir auch gleich sagen, da muss ich aber nochmal kurz nachgucken.
Wir haben auch Anteil der Nutzenden, das sind 13 Prozent der Menschen,
die irgendwie mit Software zu tun haben, haben was mit Open Source Software
zu tun oder benutzen Open Source Software.
Wir haben im ersten Halbjahr 23, 26 mal Software bestellt, 24 mal Proprietär,
einmal Open Source, einmal unbekannt.
Wissen Sie nicht so richtig, was die Lizenz ist oder haben Sie sich was bestellt?
Der Cousin vom Bruder hat irgendwie was für uns gekauft. Oder ist es dir so
eine Testlizenz oder so?
Man weiß es nicht. Vielleicht haben sie auch eine neue Lizenz,
unbekannt. Oh, oder Armin Schuster, wir dürfen gar nichts wissen.
Crowd Strike, aber das hattet ihr nicht, oder? Also es gab, es ist nichts auf
den Beinen, ich schaue es. Kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern.
Genau, es gab auch Lehrveranstaltungen, also ja, es gab eine große Auftragveranstaltung,
die hier in Dresden stattgefunden hat und da kam auch, ich war da selber auch
mit dabei, Da waren auch die Open Source Business Alliance mit dabei,
das Weizenbaum-Institut.
Wir haben da sehr, sehr viel, also wir waren viel mehr Menschen aus den ganzen
Ministerien da, als ich damit gerechnet habe.
Also der Saal war voll im Löwensaal, im Löwensaal heißt das glaube ich in Dresden.
Da war ich positiv verberechtigt.
Also da gibt es auf jeden Fall einen Need.
Das hat insbesondere hier im Südosten, generell im Süden der Republik,
ich meine jetzt der gesamten Bundesrepublik, auch eine sehr lebendige KMU-Szene
gibt, die Open Source nutzt und so und entwickelt.
Das ist ja auch ein Wirtschaftsstandortfaktor, oder? Wir haben sogar in Dresden
einen Open-Source-Software-Verein.
Ich weiß nicht, Alaska.cloud ist die Domain, Alaska.e.v.
Ist der Name. Also der beschäftigt sich tatsächlich mit Open-Source-Software
im Container- und Cluster-Bereich.
Also alles, was irgendwie mit der Cloud zu tun hat, machen die da.
Und in Leipzig macht die Software-Szene mehr Umsatz als die Automotive.
Und ja, wir sind, wir tragen auch das Software-Land Sachsen-Logo.
Ich sage ja, du hast ja eigentlich den Wirtschaftsstandort Sachsen vorangebracht,
wenn man mal das im Polit sprecht. Ich sehe das so.
Gibt auch, naja, genau.
Genau, du wolltest die Ziele noch haben, ne?
Naja, und vielleicht jetzt so im Hinblick auf diesen Bericht macht es ja dann
wahrscheinlich Sinn für die CW-Gesellschaft, diese Berichte weiterhin im Auge
zu behalten und gegebenenfalls noch weiter dafür zu sorgen, dass da mehr passiert, oder?
Eher auch eine Maßnahme. Ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn die Zivilgesellschaft
den Finger in die Wunde legt an der Stelle und dann in der Sächsischen Staatskanzlei
immer mal wieder nachfragt, wie denn der aktuelle Stand ist.
Das ist ja relativ leicht zu machen für die Zivilgesellschaft.
Sie könnte sich einen beliebigen Abgeordneten, der kooperationswillig ist,
kippen. Das geht ganz einfach.
Ich denke auch, man sucht sich den passenden Wahlkreisabgeordneten von der freundlich
ausgerichteten Partei und fragt mal, ob die eine kleine Anfrage stellen können,
wie es denn aussieht damit.
Bisher hat sich die Staatsregierung an die Aufträge aus dem Sächsischen Landtag gehalten.
Von daher gehe ich erstmal davon aus, dass man sich auch diese Ziele,
die man sich gesteckt hat, die ich jetzt mittlerweile auch gefunden habe,
dass man das auch... Und dann sagt man die Ziele.
Genau, wir haben festgelegt, dass wir für die Relation von Open Source Software
zur gesamten Softwarelandschaft zum Stichtag 30.
Juni 2028 20 Prozent haben wollen. Also eine Steigerung von den 6.000 irgendwas
Einträgen sollen in Zukunft 20% Open Source Software sein.
Entschuldigung, aber hier mischt sich schon eine gewisse Enttäuschung ein bei mir.
Das finde ich ein bisschen unambitioniert. Hätte das nicht ein bisschen mehr sein können? So 50?
Dann müsste man ja die gesamte Liste, die man jetzt schon an proprietärer Software
hat, die geht ja auch nicht weg. Naja, das wäre ja die nächste Frage.
Eher bei den Neubeschaffungen. Naja, meine Frage wäre eher zu sagen,
gibt es in dieser Open-Source-Strategie auch ein Ziel, was heißt,
irgendwie mal gucken, welche Lizenzen wir wirklich brauchen?
Also die Lizenzen, die in der Open-Source-Strategie festgelegt sind,
das sind die OSI-zertifizierten Sachen.
Also an der Stelle hat man schon aufgepasst, hat auch die Open-Source-Business-Alliance
und so weiter, auch die Zivilgesellschaft mit an der richtigen Stelle ihrer
Meinung. Ja, aber schneller ging es nicht.
Also man konnte jetzt nicht sagen, also 20 Prozent haben wir dann mal in der
öffentlichen Verwaltung Software beschafft.
Ja, ja, ach man, ja, die Realität. ...vier Jahren verändern kann.
Also die Ziele der Strategie gehen alle auf 2028, da hat man quasi eine Legislaturzeit.
Oder könnte man jetzt sagen, man muss dicke Bretter bohren.
Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht. Wir wollen 25 Prozent in Zukunft als komplette
Open-Source-Neubeauftragung machen.
Wir wollen 2024 dem Zendes beitreten, also dem Zentrum für digitale Souveränität.
Wir wollen OpenDesk, also den digitalen Arbeitsplatz in der Verwaltung einführen in Sachsen.
Wir haben, soweit ich das schon gesehen habe, einen sächsischen Account auf OpenCode.
Wir haben auch tatsächlich schon Open-Source-Projekte, die da vorbereitet werden,
da hochgeladen zu werden.
Also diesen Tanker umzudrehen oder in eine bestimmte Richtung zu lenken,
das ist schon nicht so einfach.
Und auch wenn du jetzt vielleicht höhere Zahlen erwartet hättest,
ich vielleicht auch, aber ich weiß nicht, wenn du mich gefragt hast,
bevor ich in den Sächsischen Landtag gekommen bin, 2018 oder was,
ob das das Ziel ist, was wir erreichen können, hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht gesagt.
Der Punkt ist wahrscheinlich der Tanker, den du erwähnst. Also,
dass du jetzt sagst, das ist eben ein großes Gebilde, was man da einfach nur
so sehr langsam in eine andere Richtung bewegen kann, wie man das eben mit der
Metapher Tanker sich gut vorstellen kann.
Ich muss vielleicht noch dazu sagen, wir hatten, wie wahrscheinlich in jedem
Bundesland auch, wir hatten ja gerade schon mal Corona-Pandemie,
Anfang die Diskussion um die Corona-Warn-App.
Und viele Bundesländer sind da in diese Luka-Falle getappt und viel Geld verschwendet
worden. Und naja, wir haben das in Sachsen nicht gemacht.
Wir waren, glaube ich, das erste Bundesland, was in der Corona-Schutz-Verordnung
die Corona-Warn-App aufgenommen hatte.
Das war ein, wie ich finde, damals ein Meilstein.
Und wir es alle erst mal verstanden haben, was wir für Diskussionen geführt
haben, wie diese Corona-Warn-App funktioniert
und diese ganzen Dezentral-Versus-Zentral-Geschichten und so weiter.
Das war schon... Ja, wir könnten im TTC auch ein Lied davon singen. Also so ist es nicht.
Aber es war immerhin erfolgreich.
Da hat sich ja die Zivilgesellschaft durchgesetzt am Ende und das war wirklich
toll mit zu beobachten und das hat auch, zumindest war das meine Beobachtung,
in der sächsischen Staatsregierung, das ist ja sozusagen mein Wirkkreis,
in dem ich irgendwas mitbekomme,
hat das zu einem positiven Umdenken gebracht.
Geführt, dass das jetzt nicht das Teufelszeug ist und dass das irgendwie doch
vielleicht gar keine so eine dumme Idee ist, wenn man öffentliche Gelder verwendet,
dass da am Ende ein öffentliches Gut rauskommt.
Das ist auch die Erfahrung, die ich beim Sächsischen Digitalpreis gemacht habe.
Dann kommt die Leiterin der Digitalagentur Sachsen nach der Verleihung des Open-Source-Preises zu mir.
Ah, jetzt habe ich das verstanden mit dem Open-Source-Gedanken.
Das ist ja so eine menschliche Geschichte.
Ja, also zur Erklärung, da sind, der den ersten Preis an der Stelle hat das
Gieß-Mein-Kiez-Projekt aus Leipzig gewonnen.
Das ist, glaube ich, ein Ableger aus Berlin, also wo man einen Baum adoptieren kann und dann sieht,
wie viel es geregnet hat und ob der gegossen werden muss und sich quasi mit
Daten aus der Stadt für die Stadt gegen den Klimawandel mit Open-Source-Vaffaires einsetzen kann.
Und diese Geschichte konnte so, das war so eine schöne, herzliche Gemeinschaft
oder gemeinwohlorientierte Geschichte, da haben alle verstanden diesen Gedanken,
der hinter Open Source Software steckt.
Manchmal sind es ja auch die kleinen Projekte, die greifbar werden und mit denen
man was vermitteln kann, was viel, viel größer ist. Ja, das stimmt.
Man vergisst das manchmal in dieser irgendwie Nerd- und Tech-Community.
Dass die Gedanken, die hier jemand kennt, die hinter Open Source stecken,
nicht Allgemeinwissen sind und dass man die erst vermitteln muss.
Nein, also zu erklären, was Open-Source-Software ist, war eine der Hauptaufgaben
in den letzten fünf Jahren.
Also das war immer wieder überhaupt das Verständnis, wie Software im Allgemeinen
funktioniert. Und wir haben ja heute irgendwie noch gar nicht über KI gesprochen.
Das soll ja jetzt in Zukunft alle Probleme sein. Doch, doch,
wir haben mit einem KI-Witz angefangen. Hattest du nicht mal ein Startup mit
KI? Du hast das nur anders genannt.
Das hat er nicht so genannt, deswegen war es nicht so erfolgreich.
Also ich muss jetzt mal noch kurz was anderes loswerden. Also du hast vorhin
irgendwie dem Frust ja relativ deutlich Ausdruck verliehen, aber jetzt habe
ich einen ganz anderen Eindruck.
Also jetzt habe ich den Eindruck, dass du auch sehr gerne diese gestaltende
Politik gemacht hast. Ja, natürlich.
Wenn es erfolgreich ist, weil das bestimmt nicht in allen Fällen war,
aber wenn es jetzt erfolgreich ist, dir auch Freude macht, was hast du dir jetzt vermittelt?
Landespolitik kann Spaß und Erfolge bringen, richtig?
Ja, definitiv. Ich habe ein so schönes Beispiel, bei dem das wirklich so ganz
klassisch wird. Also ich habe ein Komma und zwei Wörter in den Koalitionsvertrag
eingefügt. Komma, Jugendhakt.
Das waren die effektivsten zwei, drei Wörter in dem ganzen, also für mich auf
jeden Fall, in dem Koalitionsvertrag.
Und das hat hier zu, keine Ahnung,
drei neuen Labs und also die Arbeit hat Jugendhakt gemacht, nicht ich.
Aber die Förderung ist da durchgekommen und wir hatten hier Hackkartons und so weiter.
Es war ja nicht das Komma und die zwei Worte, sondern am Ende hast du ja den
Koalitionsvertrag mit Leben erfüllt, indem du dich dafür politisch eingesetzt
hast, dass diese zwei Worte nach dem Komma auch irgendwie umgesetzt werden und praktische.
Naja, so ein Koalitionsvertrag, so ein
von der Koalition beschlossener Koalitionsvertrag, der ist schon was wert.
Oh come on, also Koalitionsverträge haben wir wirklich von Mengen gelesen.
Okay, aber vielleicht, ich fand das eigentlich gerade ein schönes,
positives Ende, bevor wir über uneingehaltene Koalitionsvertragsversprechen sprechen.
Das ist ein anderes Thema, Sicherheitspaket.
Also wir haben ja schon viel über EU, UN, Bundestag und so gesprochen.
Das ist auch irgendwie alles relativ gleich frustrierend. Aber ich finde,
was irgendwie jetzt hier nochmal ganz schön klar geworden ist.
Ist, dass man natürlich auch auf Landesebene sich für Dinge einsetzen kann und
dass da vielleicht auch die Schwelle ein bisschen niedriger ist,
an die Politikmachenden zu kommen,
weil man eine Ansprechperson vor Ort hat und dann auch irgendwie die Macht vor
Ort, dann auch vielleicht Gesetze umzusetzen oder nochmal den Finger draufzulegen und zu schauen,
dass Projekte auch irgendwie wirklich zustande kommen.
Und das trägt ja auch dazu bei, dass es irgendwie eine Form von Selbstwirksamkeit gibt.
Und ich glaube, das ist irgendwie immer ganz wichtig, wenn man sich aktivistisch
beteiligt, dass man dieses Selbstwirksamkeitsgefühl hat, um dabei zu bleiben
und nicht nur so Screaming into the void.
Und ich glaube, das ist das, was ich für mich mitnehmen werde und vor allen
Dingen, was ich auch irgendwie Menschen mitgeben will, die mich auch häufig
fragen, was sie denn machen können, um sich politisch zu engagieren,
dass es vielleicht nicht immer die EU oder der Bundestag sein muss,
sondern dass man auf Landesebene auch schon ganz schön viel bewegen kann und
ganz schön viel ändern kann.
Und nicht so weit reisen muss und auch nicht irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
Änderungsanträge, Galore lesen muss bis zum Umfallen.
Ich glaube, das wäre so für mich der Take-away. Oder möchtet ihr da noch was hinzufügen?
Sag mal überhaupt, wie du resümieren würdest. Für dich ist ja jetzt auch ein
gewisser Haken an dieser Zeit. Was würdest du denn resümieren?
Also unterschreibst du das, was Khaleesi jetzt gesagt hat? Oder würdest du da
eher ein bisschen widersprechen?
Oder was hinzufügen? Ja, ich hätte gesagt, wenn man die Chat-Kontrolle verhindern
will, dann lohnt es sich nicht zwingend zu einem Landtagsabgeordneten zu gehen.
Ah, nee, also Daniel, dann musst du jetzt aber kurz nochmal,
also du bist ja auch Parteipolitiker, also ich meine, und die Grünen sind jetzt Regierungspartei.
Wenn man jetzt die Chat-Kontrolle verhindern will, kann man schon auch zu dir
als Landtagsabgeordneten gehen und sagen, mach dich mal stark in deiner Partei, oder?
Definitiv. Und ich habe das auch gemacht. Wir haben ja quasi Arbeitskreise und
sind auch innerhalb der Digitalpolitiker, bei uns Grün zumindest, vernetzt.
Und ich habe auch die ein oder andere E-Mail an Europaabgeordnete geschrieben
und telefoniert, was das Thema angeht.
Aber dann hört es dann auf von dem, was ich machen kann. Und ich habe das auch
bei anderen Landespolicygern versucht.
Und naja, die haben halt vielleicht nicht den informatischen Background und
verstehen das Problem nicht.
Und ob die das dann weitergeben, weiß ich nicht. Man sollte es trotzdem probieren.
Ich glaube, in dem Fall ist, warum nicht? Also man kann auch direkt die Europa
abgucken. Ja, aber ich glaube, da muss man auch immer realistisch bleiben.
Also mir ging es jetzt nicht darum, konkrete Gesetzesvorhaben zu verhindern,
wie die Chatkontrolle, dass das ein EU-Gesetz ist, dass man auch irgendwie auf
die EU-Gebene regeln muss, ist völlig klar.
Ich meinte eher so für das größere digitalpolitische Vorankommen ist ja sozusagen
ein Bundesland und die Digitalpolitik, die da vor Ort passiert,
auch ein Baustein davon, dass wir progressive Digitalpolitik machen können,
weil wir halt immer noch eine föderale Struktur haben.
Das war glaube ich gerade den Hebel, den ich eher beschreiben wollte.
Also ich möchte ein Plädoyer dafür halten, dass bitte alle ihre regionalen Landtagsabgeordneten
mit ihrem Lieblingsthema nerven.
Ich habe, das habe ich in den fünf Jahren immer wieder gemerkt,
dass da so eine Art Barriere existiert, die irgendwie gar nicht sein müsste.
Also es gibt so ein, ich habe das ja bei mir persönlich.
Bevor ich Abgeordneter gewesen bin, auch irgendwie gemerkt, dass man so eine
gewisse Hürde empfindet, jetzt diese Personen anzusprechen, obwohl die genau
dafür da sind, angesprochen zu werden.
Das ist meine Hauptaufgabe, dass ich mich um die Probleme, die zu mir getragen
werden, mich kümmere. Und das gilt nicht für mich, sondern auch für alle anderen.
Und von daher bitte geht mit den Themen, die euch irgendwie betreffen und die
euch am Herzen liegen, zu euren Vertretern.
Und bitte geht nicht nur, also wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie Klimapolitik macht,
zu den Grünen. Bitte geht auch zu den anderen Parteien, zu allen anderen Parteien.
In der Vergangenheit war das auch immer so, dass, keine Ahnung,
die Einzigen, die zugehört haben, sind dann wir bei den Klimasachen und dann
kriegt man dann auch den Frust ab, wenn man irgendwie,
naja, was entscheiden muss, was vielleicht nicht jetzt so mega cool war und
da fehlt mir die Ansprache der anderen Parteien immer. Aber wie gesagt, meldet euch.
Okay, also ich hätte diverse andere Fragen, muss ich sagen.
Ich glaube, so dieser Arbeitsalltag im Landtag und als Abgeordneter,
der hat viele spannende Aspekte.
Wirst du denn dein Wissen, du hast jetzt auch Prozesswissen,
du hast inhaltliches Wissen, das hast du dir an eigenem Müssen und teilweise
schon mit reingebracht, aber du hast jetzt auch Prozesswissen,
also wie laufen Sachen und so.
Wirst du das noch irgendwie weitergeben? Ich habe dieses Prozesswissen versucht zu digitalisieren.
Ich habe eine interne Wissensdatenbank aufgebaut mit Markdown,
Zettelkasten und so weiter.
Hast du auch einen Blog, haben wir auch gesehen. Ich habe einen Blog,
da stehen auch ganz viele Dinge, aber da ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so das Prozesswissen drin.
Aber ich habe das versucht strukturiert aufzuarbeiten, dass ich irgendwie nachzuvollziehen
kann, in welchem Protokoll hat welche Person welches Thema besprochen.
Und wenn irgendwann klar ist, welche Ministerien es gibt, welche Ausschüsse
es gibt, wer welche Themen bei uns in der Fraktion betrifft.
Natürlich versuche ich eine Übergabe so gut wie möglich zu machen,
damit in Zukunft klar ist, wo die Linien in der Vergangenheit waren.
Wo man vielleicht noch was machen kann und wo nicht. Also das steht auf jeden Fall auf der Agenda.
Also ich bin ja auch nicht weg. Also ich habe die Telefonnummern und die Threber
und Signal-IDs und so weiter von den Leuten und spreche und telefoniere auch
und schreibe mit denen noch.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir sind gut in der Zeit, hätte ich fast gesagt.
Es ist jetzt gleich Viertel nach zehn.
Deswegen erstmal vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Das hat mir großen Spaß gemacht.
Und ich glaube, der Aufruf ist klar. Ja, hier kontaktiert eure Abgeordneten,
das ist mein Lieblingssatz, aber diesmal so richtig, den könnt ihr dann auch
noch vor Ort auf die Nerven gehen,
denn das hat natürlich auch sehr viel Wirkung und dann freuen wir uns,
wenn ihr das nächste Mal wieder Dicke Bretter einschaltet.
Diese Folge wird nach der Folge über die Sachverständigenanhörungen erscheinen.
Bei chaosradio.de, wo wir im Wechsel mit dem normalen Chaos Radio die dicke
Bretter Folgen veröffentlichen dürfen.
Mithilfe der Chaos Radio Crew und der Musik von Erdgeist wollen wir kurz hier
mal erwähnen, denn ohne die könnten wir das ja nicht machen.
Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir sind bestimmt noch ein bisschen da und
beantworten euch gerne Fragen.
Music.